call of duty vanguard is getting a free
alpha this weekend the first images from
the live action cowboy bebop film have
been released and the playstation 5 is
getting a new model sorta my name is
davonte chisholm and you're watching
gamespot news
after being officially revealed last
week playstation players will have the
first opportunity to try out the next
entry in the call of duty franchise
titled vanguard starting on august 27th
at 10 a.m pacific and 1pm eastern anyone
with the playstation 4 or 5 can download
an alpha for the game complete with the
debut of a new game mode called champion
hill according to the announcement post
champion help hits multiple squads
against each other in a round robin
tournament on a large map that's split
into five sections during the call of
duty vanguard alpha squads will be
limited to two or three members but
larger games with more players may be
included during a beta or when the game
launches according to that same post
players will have access to some of the
game's arsenal and even be able to
customize weapons with up to 10
attachments playstation owners will also
be able to play without playstation plus
the alpha will end august 29th at 10 a.m
pacific 1 pm eastern and players who are
eager to hop in can pre-load it starting
today two other betas are currently
scheduled for the game as well with a
beta for playstation owners who have
pre-ordered the game set to take place
september 10 to 13. and if you're really
excited for vanguard make sure you check
out our impressions video up on the site
right now richie and erin got a chance
to look at extended gameplay and i'll
tell you all about it but in other
playstation related news sony has
updated the playstation 5's design
however the changes are so subtle you
may have never noticed them the
australian site press start noticed the
models in the wild followed by eurogamer
finding them in the uk according to
those reports the new model is roughly
0.6 pounds lighter than the original ps5
model though it's unclear what sony may
have changed about the production to
account for the weight difference the
more noticeable change from a consumer
angle is the addition of a thumb screw
so you can adjust the stand by hand
whereas the previous model required a
screwdriver but okay netflix's live
action adaptation of the hit anime
cowboy bebop is coming to the streaming
service on november 19th with this
announcement of the premiere date
netflix has also released images from
the show as well and they look
surprisingly good i mean it's refreshing
considering netflix's past live-action
anime adaptations in the first images of
spike played by john cho we see the
character has his signature blue suit
with yellow shirt underneath and yes the
headphones are there as well the
original anime followed a group of
bounty hunters who are according to the
official synopsis quote on the run from
their past as they hunt down the solar
system's most dangerous criminals
they'll even save the world for the
right price i for one am really excited
about this i'm gonna wait for a trailer
to get like super hyped about it but
cowboy bebop was one of the first animes
to really get me into anime so i'm
curious i wanna i wanna see how this
goes all right that's it for me make
sure you let me know if you're excited
for the vanguard out for this weekend
stay tuned to the channel because we'll
be streaming it on friday and for more
subscribe to gamespot on youtube or
visit us at gamespot.com
[Music]
you